thank you so much
for coming you know I spent four of the
most formative years of my life as a
student here in Berkeley and it's always
a very emotional for me to come back so
so I called the talk yeah
black holes firewalls and the limits of
quantum computers black holes and
firewalls were mostly just to get you in
the building you know I'm you know I'll
say something about them at the end you
know quantum quantum computers when I do
a Google image search for quantum
computer that's one of the first things
that comes up now you know I'm you know
it'll become clear in this talk that I'm
not an engineer I'm a theorist but I
don't think that's what they look like
I've been in enough lab tours that you
know they they look a lot messier than
that okay so and by the way you can find
the slides and you know a bunch of sort
of our articles that you know from
technical to popular about many of the
things I'll be talking about on my home
page okay so my starting point here is
you know not about quantum mechanics
it's just about the limits of technology
okay there are certain things that would
be awesome to have again we never seem
to see them first of all warp drive you
know where is it I've been waiting since
I was a kid okay secondly the perpetual
motion machine you know the only real
solution to our energy problems okay and
then thirdly is what I'll call the uber
computer okay and this is a machine that
you know doesn't necessarily tell you
the meaning of life or anything like
that you know but it immediately answers
any well posed mathematical question
that you put to it okay so here we see
it saying you know Goldbach's conjecture
true next question you know what you
know it's just saying you know yes every
even number four or greater is the sum
of two prime numbers right you know you
know I think some people have the
impression that this is already what
computers are okay but you know we one
of the the most basic things we teach in
the theory of computing is that you know
even the fastest computers today you
know or are powerless against certain
kinds of problems they have
limitations there are certain problems
like the halting problem you know to
tell whether a given program will ever
stop running which are proven to be
unsolvable you know in that case by Alan
Turing in the 1930s there are other
programs as there other problems that
computers can solve but only we think by
using astronomical amounts of time okay
so now um I'd like to make the
observation that you know in the first
two of these cases you know we can say
something about why these technologies
are not around you know which is more
illuminating than just well you know the
engineers ran out of money before they
could build it or something like that
okay we can connect this to you know
fundamental principles of physics okay
in the case of warp drive well you know
those principles are those of a special
relativity which tell us that if you
could send the signal faster than light
then in someone's frame of reference
you're sending that signal backwards in
time okay and then you know you've got
to worry about well what happens if you
go back in time and you kill your
grandfather for therefore you're never
born but therefore no one kills your
grandfather
therefore you are born and you know you
know no one wants to worry about that
stuff okay so you know the in the case
of the perpetual motion machine you know
of course what rules it out is the
increase of entropy the second will of
thermodynamics okay but what about the
third case so you know are there
principles of physics that you know tell
us what computations we can and can't
perform so you know that question is is
sort of the starting point for me okay
you know what this physics tell us about
the limits of computers and if we
understand those limits can they then
feed back and tell us anything new about
physics okay so I guess I'll take five
minutes to give you a crash course on
you know some of the basic concepts of
you know the theory of computing yeah
that's that's that that's all I should
need for the
talk okay so you know we we a computer
scientists like to take sort of any
concept or notion of what a computer
could be and associate to it some
inscrutable sequence of capital letters
okay so you know the most these give
gives us things called complexity
classes which are sort of you know one
of the the most basic objects that we
study okay and the may be the sort of
central complexity class is called P for
polynomial time okay and you can think
of it informally as you know the class
of all the problems that are solvable
efficiently by a standard digital
computer like the one in your pocket
okay
you know I you know you formally you
would say you know a Turing machine
which is the mathematical model of what
a computer is laid down by Alan Turing
in 1936 but today it's you know it's
easier just to say the thing that's in
your pocket okay you know so what do we
mean by efficiently well we have a sort
of rough-and-ready criterion for that
that it means solvable using a number of
steps that grows at most like the size
of a problem instance raised to some
fixed power okay like you know the size
of the problem square the size of the
problem cubed okay and by the way by a
problem we mean sort of you know an
infinite collection of let's say yes or
no questions okay so here would be an
example right so this is this is a you
know we could consider what's called the
connectivity problem okay where I give
you a description you know a map
described somehow as a string of bits
and I ask you you know is a given point
connected to a given other one okay an
instance of this problem which
confronted me this past week is is it
mathematically possible to get between
Berkeley and Palo Alto
you know what if there's traffic okay so
you know this is a famous example of a
problem that is solvable in the class P
in fact there is a linear time algorithm
you know which will get invoked anytime
you use Google Maps basically okay so
you know so this so this is something
that is you know that we consider
efficiently solvable same with you know
multiplying numbers same with same same
with sorting and you know most of the
other things that a computer would do on
a day to day basis okay yeah you know
and people object to the definition by
the way because if you had a an
algorithm that took you know like the
problem size raised to the million power
time
well that's formally polynomial but you
wouldn't want to run that for you know
any problem size larger than one okay
but you know in practice that tends not
to happen so you know so between friends
we like to say you know polynomial means
efficient and you know if there are
exceptions to that then we deal with
them when they come okay so so then the
second important class is called NP
non-deterministic polynomial time misses
the class of problems for which well you
know maybe they're not solvable by an
efficient algorithm but at least you
know if there is a solution then that
solution can be efficiently checked you
know you can be recognized when you're
showing it okay so well one of the most
famous examples of an NP problem is a
factoring factoring numbers okay so you
know if I want to phrase this as a
yes-or-no question
I could give you a large number like
that one there and say you know does it
have a prime factor that ends in seven
okay well you know has anyone solved it
yet okay so I think in this case the
answer is yes but you know I made this
slide a long time ago and
if if the answer is no I'm not sure you
know well you know so so you know so so
so the thing to notice is that you know
uh you know if someone has solved this
problem then you know it's it's pretty
easy at least with a computer to check
their solution okay you know as it turns
out this is not quite obvious but there
are very fast algorithms that can tell
you whether a number is composite or
prime okay if it's composite they tell
you nothing about what the divisors are
okay but they but they do tell you if
it's prime or not so you could you know
give someone the you know divisors of
this number a person could use their
computer multiply them that's that's an
easy operation check that you know they
do multiply to this thing and also check
that they're prime and then just check
whether one of them ends and seven okay
but if someone didn't tell you
you know what the divisors were well you
might spend quite a bit of time looking
for them right and you know in fact many
of you might know that the security of
you know essentially all the
cryptography that we use on the Internet
today is based on the belief that
factoring and a few closely related
problems are hard okay for you know that
there is not going to be any efficient
algorithm to solve these problems
you know solution is is much much easier
to check than it is to find okay you
know so anytime you see a little padlock
icon on your web browser or an HTTP
right you're you know you're your
information like your credit card number
is being protected by a credit card or a
code that depends on the belief that
this kind of problem is hard
okay well we'll come back to that so so
then you know a further crucial concept
is np-hard problems these are problems
that are sort of at least as hard as any
problem in NP in the sense that if you
had a magic box to solve them then you
could use that magic box to solve any
other end people
okay well that's so you know we're
definition not clear that there's any
problems like that but there are there's
oodles of them okay and then the
np-complete problems are the np-hard
problems which are also themselves in NP
so those are sort of like the maximally
hard problems whose solutions are still
easy to check
you know the maximally hard NP problems
okay now a central discovery that you
know in the early 1970s that you know
really started you know theoretical
computer science as sort of its own
field was the discovery which was you
know in which I was a which was really
sort of which a central participant was
the guy who introduced me just now a
carp that not just one or two but many
many many hundreds of the problems that
people actually care about and actually
want to solve happen to fall into this
np-complete class okay a famous example
being the problem you know I give you a
map like this and I ask not what is the
shortest path or is there a path from A
to B but just is there a path that hits
each vertex in this case exactly once
okay in this case what's the answer
anyone yeah yes it's easier to see when
you color it okay okay so you may have
heard the the literally million-dollar
question of this field is you know
whether P is equal to NP that is you
know for every efficiently checkable
problem is it also efficiently solvable
okay this question has entered popular
culture you know it's been on The
Simpsons Futurama other TV shows and
movies that are not as good it's you
know it's also one of the seven clay
problems for which you know you get a
million dollar prize for a solution
alongside the Riemann hypothesis
the punker a conjecture which was
actually solved by Perlman although he
declined the prize and and for other
problems okay now my personal opinion is
that P versus NP is actually manifestly
the most important of all these problems
okay that it is the biggest problem in
mathematics and my argument for that is
simply well if P were equal to NP and if
moreover the you know algorithm were
really efficient in practice so you know
not n to the 1 million or something like
that well then that would ants I'll
answer this question but it would also
mean that we could answer the other 6
questions because we would simply
program our computer to find the answers
for us ok you know the problem like you
know given a mathematical statement
written in some formal language like
that of set theory you know is there a
formal proof of this statement with it
most you know a given number of symbols
like you know a million or a billion
that is an NP problem so if P were equal
to NP that would be an efficiently
solvable problem ok so that that I I
hope you know helps to underscore the
enormity of what we're asking right if P
were equal so I'm you know this meta
mathematical importance was recognized
early on by girdle you know
incompleteness guy in a letter to John
von Neumann where were you know in 1956
ok uh you know I mean if P were equal to
NP that would also break essentially all
of the cryptography that we use today
everything except stuff like the
one-time pad which you know doesn't
depict rebuking which don't depend on
mathematical assumptions ok so you know
or are they equal or not you know I like
to summarize it by saying that if we
were physicists as opposed to math and
CS people we would have simply declared
P not equal to NP to be a law of nature
ok and we would we would have we would
have given our you know we would have
said you know of course you know you
know look we tried we looked for an
algorithm is not there of course
can't solve it right what what are you
gonna do you know you've got you know a
certain gigantic search space to to the
end possibilities yeah maybe you can cut
it down a little here thereby being
clever but you know polynomial come on
right and yeah we would have given
ourselves Nobel Prizes for that
discovery okay and you know and by the
way if someone later proved that
actually P equals NP well we just would
have given ourselves more nobel prizes
for for the laws overthrow okay so you
know but but you know you know they're
they're sort of you know one thing you
learn in quantum computing it's an
interdisciplinary field you know in
different fields have different
terminology so you know what the
physicists call law we call a conjecture
okay so yeah so okay so so this okay so
um but you know even if we you know
except that you know probably presumably
you know P is not equal to NP you know
and we hope someday to be able to prove
such things but you know we seem a long
way from that now you know one can then
you know ask a further question okay P
versus NP itself you know is a purely
mathematical question right you know it
has a you know whatever's the answer it
has an answer right which is totally
independent of whatever the laws of
physics are right because you know it
just ask you know is there at this
touring machine or not okay so you know
it doesn't even make sense to ask well
is you know this quantum mechanics
change the answer at a P versus NP no of
course it doesn't okay but there there
is then a further question you can ask
which is well supposing P is not equal
to NP is there any physical means at all
to solve np-complete problems
efficiently possibly a means that would
exceed you know the capabilities of
Turing machines right because a touring
machine is just one particular
mathematical idealization of what a
computer is okay it's not obvious that
the laws of physics you know restrict us
to that kind of computer right maybe
they let us do something else
okay so so you know when we ask sort of
what are the ultimate limits of of
computers that we could actually build
well then of course we're asking a
question about physics and physics is
going to enter the discussion okay
so so you know they're you know you know
the idea that the limits of what we can
compute in the physical universe sort of
coincide with the you know limits of a
Turing machine is sometimes called the
church touring thesis okay although it's
not clear that church or touring
themselves ever said that or believed
that but you know it's sort of like you
know well if they didn't say it they
should have okay you know but then you
know you you could make an even stronger
belief which is that you know whatever
is efficiently computable in the
physical world should be efficiently
computable you know in the sense of
polynomial time by a Turing machine okay
but now we're really sticking our necks
out and we're really making a
falsifiable empirical claim about nature
right you know you know Nate you know
nature doesn't have to listen to us you
know you know you know or you know if we
even you know if we enunciate it as a
principle right nature might go and
ignore that principle okay so so so it
behooves us to ask you know what is
there in nature that could conceivably
challenge that you know extended Church
touring thesis right what could a
physical system look like that could you
know possibly exceed the limits of a
Turing machine okay so you know you
probably all know where this is going
you know given the title of the talk but
you know before we get the quantum
computers let's just briefly discuss a
few other examples okay
so there's an old proposal I like which
is that you take two glass plates you
put pegs between them and whatever
pattern you want and you dip the
resulting contraption into a tub of
soapy water then you take it out and you
look at the soap bubbles that form in
between the pegs okay and bubbles like
the sort of relaxed to their lowest
energy state which in this case you know
presumably means sort of minimizing the
total length of bubble
you know going in between these pegs but
now you know if I if I ask you what's
the minimum total length of line
segments connecting a set of points in
the plane where those line segments
could also meet at intermediate points
like these well this is called the
minimum Steiner tree problem and this is
a famous example of one of those np-hard
problems okay so now we're faced with a
puzzle which is basically you know how
you know if this problem is np-hard well
then how does nature solve it okay how
does nature do this and you know is it
possible that you know a tub of soapy
water does what all of our super
computers cannot do and that you know we
could you know just have like you know
so soap tubs you know to break all the
cryptographic codes that you know over
you know all of our enemies are using
okay so well you know there was a
discussion of this on the internet some
you know years ago and you know and and
and some people said well you know
there's they're sort of no no reason for
to you know to imagine that this will
always work right because systems in
nature like to relax to their lowest
energy state they can often be modeled
as doing that but you know they can get
stuck they don't always succeed as an
example if I put a rock on a crevice on
a mountainside well it could reach a
state of lower potential energy by
rolling up first and then rolling down
but it's rarely observed to do that okay
so you know so why shouldn't be imagine
that the same is true here that you
would get stuck in a so-called local
optimum all right well so then someone
else came and said you know but this is
just an academic computer scientist
party-line you will repeat that you Pat
yourselves on the back I bet not one of
you has they've ever tried the
experiment you have no idea what would
happen all right oh I told you that I'm
a theorist this led me to the one foray
into experimental physics in my career
where I I used to take this around and
do demonstrations but it was just hell
to get it through airport security so
you know what what I found when I tried
it is that indeed you know with four or
five pegs or so you usually do get the
minimum steiner trait and it's cool to
watch you can try it at home so if you
do I recommend using Plexiglas instead
of glass so you don't cut your hands I
asked how I know okay so but you know
but then you know if you know when you
scale up more say to six pegs seven pegs
then it doesn't always find the optimal
solution in fact sometimes you find a
little cycle of bubble which is then
like a proof that it can't be minimal
okay so you know I didn't try every
possible brand of soap but you know I I
think you know I think we have some
certainly some circumstantial evidence
that nature is not solving np-complete
problems by magic this way right you
know and that means that may sound silly
and yet every year or so you'll see in
the popular press another headline about
you know biological system that solves
np-complete problems you know protein
folding right you know nature just you
know every cell of your body solves an
np-complete problem every second but you
know just letting the proteins fold into
their lowest energy state okay I think
that similar comments apply you know in
that case you know with proteins well
there was strong a selection pressure on
them right if like one could in
principle may create a an amino acid
chain such that you know to fold it into
its lowest energy state you would need
to prove the Riemann hypothesis first
right this is what np-hardness means
okay but that would be a pretty bad
protein right it wouldn't you know you
know so so like proteins that get
selected will tend to be ones that do
fold reliably even then there are
proteins that can miss fold get stuck in
local optima prions the agent of mad cow
disease are apparently an example of
that okay so all right my second example
is you know you know we you hear about
quantum computers all the time but why
not a relativity computer okay so the
idea here would be quite simple you
start your computer working on some hard
problem then you leave your computer on
earth new board a spaceship which in you
accelerate to relativistic speed okay
and then you decelerate you return to
Earth okay back in Earth's reference
frame
you know billions of years have now
elapsed okay
civilization has collapsed actually you
know in our timeline civilization
probably collapses by 2019 or something
but you know you know at any rate it's
it's it's it's it certainly collapsed
you know by then okay but you know if
you can you know just sort of somehow
dig your computer out of the rubble and
it somehow can it still connect it to a
power source then you can read out the
answer to your hard problem
okay's to me this just raises an
immediate question which is why doesn't
anyone try this I mean I mean you know
if you're worried about all your friends
being dead just bring them on this
spaceship with you you know but you know
so we're asking you know what is it in
fundamental physics that would rule this
out that would prevent you from getting
orbit Rory computational speed ups in
this sort of way so I think there's
actually an interesting answer to that
question okay and it has to do with the
amount of energy that it would take to
accelerate to you know relativistic
speed to get the speed up okay so what
you can calculate is that if you want it
and say an exponential computational
speed up this way then you would need to
get exponentially close to the speed of
light okay but to do that would require
an exponential amount of energy okay so
we've sort of just traded one
exponential for a different one right
and now you know where to imagine that
before liftoff you know you spend like
exponential time just fueling up your
spaceship you know or something like you
know well you know or where do you find
all this fuel okay so you know it's a
it's an example of how you know very
very often you'll you'll see proposals
for these sort of hyper computers you
know that would exceed the limits of
Turing machines but then on analysis
they're just based on taking one aspect
of the laws of physics in isolation and
ignoring all the other aspects okay so
that's a cost
retail right we better not do that okay
a second example along the same lines is
what I like to call the Z no computer
okay now this is simply a computer that
would do its first step in one second
the second step in half a second the
third step in a quarter second fourth
step in an eighth second and so on so
that after two seconds it would have
done infinitely many steps you know you
could solve the whole thing problem that
way okay but so so again why doesn't
anyone try that okay well in this case
thing you know in some sense there are
people who try this right there are
people who overclock their
microprocessor all right they run it
faster than you know it's supposed to
okay but many of you might know the
danger in doing that which is that if
you run your processor too fast it will
overheat it'll melt okay you know this
is why computers have fans all right
because you know you know again we can
ask well but what is the fundamental
physical limit here okay well you can
imagine trying to run a microchip faster
and faster and faster and faster clock
rate as I want to run it faster to do
that I will need more and more cooling
you know I'll start you know wanting
liquid nitrogen or liquid helium and
some supercomputers used to actually use
okay and you know and the more cooling I
need the more energy that will cost you
see once again energy okay and then once
my computer is running fast enough I
might as well just forget about the
cooling system and talk about the energy
that's inherent in the computation
itself okay now um as far as current
physics can say the fundamental limit
here seems to occur if you were to run a
computation at about 10 to the 43 Hertz
okay it's ten to the forty three
operations per second one step per
Planck time okay now you could think of
you know a toy model of such a computer
as just a photon that's bouncing back
and forth between two mirrors to count
off time steps you know and when the
mirrors would be one Planck length apart
that it's 10 to the minus 33 centimeters
okay now what's the problem
with with a computer that runs that fast
while the problem is but you know
Planck's relation e equals H V okay such
a photon would have so much energy
concentrated in so small of a region
that it would exceed what's called a
Schwarzschild radius okay that's just a
fancy way of saying that your computer
collapses through a black hole okay
which you know I've always liked this
Nature's Way of telling you not to try
something okay uh okay but what about
quantum computing I mean you know we
knew it was coming at some point those
are supposed to be spin 1/2 particles
although you know I don't think that's
actually what they look like so
all right so in order to tell you you
know you know I mean I mean I mean I
mean quantum computing you know like
when you first hear about it it sounds
you know roughly as crazy as there's
other things that I just talked about
okay and yet we know that there are
experimental groups all over the world
which are currently you know working
very hard and you know spending
significant money to try to actually
build these things okay so you know
what's the difference well you know the
quantum computers are machines that
would be do computation in a
fundamentally different way by
exploiting the rules of quantum
mechanics okay which is something that's
you know has been sort of the basic
operating system for physics since the
1920s you know the thing that everything
else sort of runs on is application
programs okay except for you know
general relativity there's some
technical problems porting it to the OS
okay but but well what is this operating
system right you know and like what what
is there that's in it of sort of
comparable enormity to the church you
know to the extended church-turing
thesis that that the one could actually
challenge the other okay so I have to
spend a couple slides telling you about
what this quantum mechanics say you know
you you might think that would take more
than a couple slides you know I mean
physicists you know
think over generations we succeeded in
convincing people that quantum mechanics
is somehow complicated or hard you know
and it's true that if you want to know
you know the ground states of you know
interesting molecules and so forth yeah
you know that's complicated okay but not
being a physicist and not being bound by
their rules I can let you in on a secret
which is that quantum mechanics is
actually incredibly simple once you take
the physics out of it okay now the way
that I think of quantum mechanics is
that it's a certain generalization of
the rules of probability themselves okay
so you know you know probability you
know you could talk about well you know
a you know a 30% chance that you know
wildfires will consume the Bay Area or
whatever but you know you would never
talk about a negative 30% chance right
let alone you know a you know an AI
percent you know square root of minus 1%
chance okay that would just be nonsense
okay but quantum mechanics fundamentally
is a generalization of the rules of
probability where to each possible way
that things could be or that we could
find things on looking at them we assign
a number called an amplitude okay and
amplitudes are a little like
probabilities in fact we use them to
calculate the probability that we'll see
a system in one state or another when we
do look at it okay but these amplitudes
are not themselves probabilities they
can be positive or negative and in fact
they can even be complex numbers okay so
you know a Richard Fineman used to say
that everything in quantum mechanics
just boils down to one experiment the
double-slit experiment so we might as
well talk about it you know the double
slit experiment is the thing where I
take photons I shoot them one by one and
a screen with two slits in it and I look
at where they end up on a second screen
and what you know and and and and where
they end up is random right with the
same initial conditions photon can
sometimes land one spot and sometimes
another you know
people go on and on about well you know
this is God playing dice Einstein
couldn't accept it but well that is not
the strange part about quantum mechanics
right if it was just probability who
cares okay we could you know invent you
know thirty theories for that before
breakfast okay the the strange part is
the way that the probabilities have to
be calculated okay because what you find
is that there are certain dark spots on
the second screen where the photon never
seems to appear or almost never okay and
yet if I close off one of the slits then
the photon can appear in those places
okay so by decreasing the number of ways
for something to happen I can increase
the chance that it happens okay
also if I just look at the photon to try
to see which slit it's going through
then I don't see this interference
pattern anymore right everybody you know
I I hasten to add it doesn't have to be
a conscious person looking at it or
anything like that if if the if the
photon is interacting in any way with
its external environment so that the
information about which slit it goes
through leaks out you know into a
recording device into the air molecules
in the room into anything then you don't
see the interference okay interference
is something that photons you know and
other particles like to enjoy in private
okay so so okay the way that quantum
mechanics explains this is by saying
that well the probability of an event in
quantum mechanics is calculated as the
squared absolute value of its amplitude
okay and the amplitude could be a sum of
of contributions you know complex
numbers representing the contributions
from all the different ways that that
thing could have happened okay and so
the result is that you know there could
be certain spots on the second screen
where the photon could arrive there
through the first slit with a positive
amplitude I or through the second slit
with a negative amplitude okay
if that happens the nose two
contributions can as we say interfere
destructively and cancel each other out
with the result being that the total
amplitude is zero and the photon is
never found there okay I close off one
of the slits and then the amplitude is
positive or negative so that I can see
it there okay
so physicists describe this by saying
you know that the state of the world is
a vector right it's a vector of complex
numbers okay and they have this strange
notation that they like to use for
vectors okay that's all this is
right so the simplest type of quantum
system is a bit which could be in a zero
state or a one state but because it's
quantum mechanics it can also have an
amplitude to be in zero and an amplitude
to be in one okay it can be in what we
call a superposition of the two states
okay a bit that can be in a
superposition of zero and one we call a
quantum bit or a qubit okay so the state
of a qubit is written as a 0 plus B 1
where a and B are just complex numbers
called amplitudes and they satisfy this
relation here
ok and this relation is sort of there to
ensure that if you look at the qubit you
know you ask it whether it's 0 or 1 well
then you know you know it tells you that
at 0 with this probability and it tells
you that it's 1 with that probability
well then those probabilities better add
up to 1 ok that's why that's there so so
the possible states of one qubit you
know if we looked at real amplitudes
only for simplicity would simply define
a circle like you know a squared plus B
squared equals 1 ok 0 could be you know
we could take to be the horizontal
Direction 1 we could take as the
vertical direction and then we can have
any possible intermediate like this
equal superposition state of 0 plus 1
over square root of 2 okay now you know
if I take a superposition like that and
I look at it I force it to make up its
mind about what it wants to be
sort of snaps to one possibility or the
other okay and you know by the way
whichever choice it makes it sticks with
it okay so you know if it tells you that
it's one and you look again it says you
know what do you want for me I'm one
okay all right so so now I can start to
tell you what is quantum computing okay
so so now the the key observation here
is imagine I have not just one qubit but
a thousand cubits or a million cubits
okay physically maybe that's like a
thousand particles that could all be
each each of which could be spinning one
way or spinning the opposite way right
oh you know I don't I don't you know it
does it doesn't actually matter for our
purposes you know what physically gives
rise to this qubit okay you know any
quantum system that has two
distinguishable States okay
but now the point is if I have a
thousand you know say of these qubits
the rules of quantum mechanics tell me
that to dispute if those qubits are
interacting with each other in some
arbitrary way then to describe their
state I actually need to assign one
amplitude for every possible
configuration of all thousands of those
bits that means two to the thousand
power amplitudes okay so you know if you
were wanted to write them down you know
that's you know way more amplitudes than
there are atoms in the observable
universe okay
and yet you know quantum mechanics has
been telling us for ninety years that
you know to just to maintain the state
of a thousand measly particles nature
off to the side somewhere has to have
some scratch paper with two to the
thousand complex numbers and every time
something happens to those particles it
has to cross off those numbers and
replace them with a new two to the
thousand numbers okay that is an immense
amount of work for nature to be going to
you know and you know I say you know and
and and it's astounding that I sort of
it it took so long for this to sink in
that quantum mechanics you know was
always saying this okay now to be fair
chemists and physicists
did you know know this for a while they
knew it mostly as a practical problem
okay what they what they knew was that
you know if you're trying to simulate
quantum mechanics on a classical
computer then the time needed for the
simulation seems to increase
exponentially with the number of
particles that you're trying to simulate
okay and so you know they invented all
kinds of approximate methods and
heuristics over the decades for getting
around that problem you know Nobel
prizes were awarded for some of the most
important ones you know and you know in
fact it's a pretty decent fraction of
supercomputer time today is used for
this problem the problem of trying to
simulate quantum mechanics you know with
large numbers of interacting particles
you know in order to learn things about
chemistry and material science and so
forth okay so it was not until the early
80s that a few physicists like Richard
Fineman and David Deutsch started asking
well why can't we turn that
computational lemon into lemonade okay
so you know if you know quantum systems
are so hard to simulate with today's
computers then why don't we build
computers that themselves take advantage
of superposition and interference of
amplitudes you know and you know
entanglement between different qubits
okay you know of course they then face
the question supposing we built such a
computer well what would it be good for
okay you know at the time they only
really had one answer to that question
which is such a computer would be good
for simulating quantum mechanics right
now you know it sounds funny but
actually you know if you know when we do
start to get practical quantum computers
I predict that quantum simulation is
still the most important application
that we know ok it has you know
potential uses from you know
understanding reaction rates and you
know industrially important processes
you know fertilizer production you know
all kinds of things
designing draw
that bind to a receptor in the right way
you know maybe you know understanding
high-temperature superconductivity
designing higher efficiency solar cells
okay and furthermore you know we are you
know pretty confident that a quantum
computer really would help for these
sorts of problems right it's you know
you know it you know it what you know
because a general quantum simulator is
exactly what you know this is sort of
its its home territory right but now if
you know the surprise the big you know
non-trivial discovery that was made in
the 1990s is that a quantum computer can
also sometimes be used to solve even
classical problems faster than we know
how to solve them with a classical
computer okay and the most famous
example of that is Shor's algorithm okay
sure sure famous algorithm actually
solves the problem of factoring an
integer which I talked about earlier in
polynomial time with a quantum computer
okay so what sure showed is you know and
related problems like discrete
logarithms elliptic curve problems and
so forth
okay with the upshot being that you know
if you build a universal quantum
computers then the assumptions that
underlie modern public key cryptography
are no longer true you can break
essentially all the systems that we use
in practice now okay this made many more
people interested in quantum computing
than had previously been you know I
should mention that there are
theoretical public key cryptosystems
that seem to be resistant even against
quantum attack such as lattice space
crypto systems okay it's just that those
are not widely deployed yet okay so you
know of course people always ask well so
so where are we with building these
things you know I'm proud to report that
you know after some you know probably a
couple billion dollars of investment in
this field and more than 20 years of
effort the experimentalist have
succeeded in factoring 21 into 3 times 7
using Shor's algorithm with high
statistical confidence I am I'm
optimistic the 35 is on the horizon you
know I mean you know you know scaling
this up is hard actually you know you
know there are more impressive things
that are you know that are likely to
happen in a few years you know this is
this this joke slide is even a little
bit outdated now okay but you know
there's a huge practical problems in
actually building this which were
understood from the beginning and you
know the the central thing is the
unwanted interaction between the qubits
and their external environment
okay the phenomenon called decoherence
okay basically you know when a quantum
computation is being run yeah you know
it is as if the entire universe is you
know or the entire rest of what you know
what say your lab is constantly trying
to peek in and see what's happening just
because of the natural you know noise
and interactions between the computer
and the external world okay but you know
you look in on a quantum computer
prematurely well I'm told that it's like
you know baking a souffle where you open
the oven before it's ready this thing
collapses okay same with quantum states
right you you know to get a quantum
computation to work you would need to
you know have the qubits incredibly well
isolated from their external environment
but then at the same time interacting
with each other and not only doing that
but doing it in a very precisely
prescribed way okay so you know that's
so hard that there were you know fit a
good number of physicists in the 90s who
said this can never happen okay this is
really impossible the you know a huge
discovery that you know changed many
people's money changed most people's
minds was called quantum fault-tolerance
which told us that we don't actually
have to have to get the decoherence down
to zero
we merely have to make it very small and
then there are very clever
error correcting codes that can take
care of the rest okay you know so qubits
are sort of just now you know get you're
just like a few years ago have gotten
good enough to apply these error
correcting
codes when you look at just a few of
them in isolation okay
the problem is as I try to scale up and
have lots and lots of qubits then the
noise rate goes back up because of
interactions between the qubits okay but
you know people are working on it and
you know Google right now has a 22 qubit
system which seems to be working pretty
well they say that within a year they
plan to upgrade that to 49 qubits okay
you know when when I heard John Martinez
of Google say that I asked him to
clarify if he meant the calendar year or
the academic year he said he said the
calendar year but it will take a lot
longer to test it and calibrate it and
so on you know he said oh you know by
December 31st we'll have something I
don't tell you it will work ok so ok but
now you know a crucial point to
understand ok is that fact the factoring
problem is neither known or believed to
be one of these np-complete ones ok
there are excellent theoretical reasons
why it should not be np-complete ok and
you know to you know if you read almost
any popular article that's ever been
written on this subject right it will
say something about it that sounds
really good and it's totally wrong ok
we'll say look you know the way a
quantum computer works is just that it
tries every possible answer in a
different parallel universe you know
it's like yeah well you know journalists
love that because you know it's like
yeah anyone can understand why that
would make it faster ok but then you
know the puzzle is well if it's that
simple then you know why did it take
people all these decades to figure to
figure it out ok so so you know the the
resolution is that with a quantum
computer you know it is easy to create a
superposition over all the possible
solutions to your problem right that you
know you can you can do very easily but
for it to be useful well at some point
you've got to measure the thing you've
got to get an answer out ok and if I
just take an equal superposition over
all answers and I measure it not having
done anything else then the rules of
quantum mechanics say
all I'm gonna get out will be a random
answer yeah you know if I just wanted a
random answer well I could have picked
one myself with a lot less trouble okay
so for that reason the entire hope of
getting a speed advantage from a quantum
computer is to rely on the way that
these amplitudes behave differently from
ordinary probabilities and in particular
the fact that being complex numbers they
can interfere with each other okay so
the idea with every quantum algorithm is
to choreograph things in such a way that
for each wrong answer some of the paths
leading there have positive amplitudes
and others have negative amplitudes so
on the whole they cancel each other out
whereas the pairs that lead to the right
answer should all be in phase with each
other say all positive or all negative
if I could arrange that then when I
measure I'll see the right answer with a
good probability you know which you know
if I even if I have a 70% chance of
getting the right answer that's great
just run it several times you know take
the majority vote okay so um um so so so
you know a huge question that people
asked at the beginning of this field was
well could there be a an efficient
quantum algorithm to solve not merely
factoring but all the NP problems right
here to solve the np-complete problems
okay well uh you know I I hope no one
will be shocked if I reveal that the
answer is we don't know okay you know
you know can we prove that quantum
computers can't solve these problems
well of course we can't prove that
because we can't even prove that
classical computers can't do it okay
that's the P versus NP problem okay but
you know we can say is that at the least
if there were fast quantum algorithm to
solve the np-complete problems then it
would have to look totally different
from Shor's algorithm or from any of the
other quantum algorithms that we know ok
so quantum speed-up seemed to you know
be more specialized this this whole
thing of choreographing the interfere
rent pattern it works for problems that
have a special kind of structure to them
you know in the case of factoring sure
really took heavy advantage of this sort
of number theory and group Theory
structure and the problem to sort of
choreograph a set of operations which we
call the quantum Fourier transform that
gives you the right kind of interference
pattern we don't know how to do that for
np-complete problems ok and in fact we
have an important result about it so my
my advisor at Berkeley Oh mesh Raza
Ronnie along with the Bennet Bernstein
and Brassard proved in the 90s that if I
just imagine say an abstract space of 2
to the N possible solutions and if the
only thing I knew how to do was you know
for each solution just check whether
it's valid or not valid right and I'm
searching for a valid solution ok call
this black box search right well then
you know with a classical computer it's
pretty obvious that well you know I'm
gonna have to open about 2 to the N
boxes to find this little right you know
what else am I gonna do alright you know
but now imagine that I can open many
different boxes in superposition ok so
with some amplitude I can open the first
box with some other amplitude I can open
the second box and so on and then I get
a superposition of answers then I can
you know transform that state some more
I can make another superpose query to
the boxes ok in that case um there is an
amazing algorithm called Grover's
algorithm which lets me find a solution
with only about the square root of the
number of steps that I would have needed
classically ok so in this case that
means 2 to the N over 2 steps okay but
what Bandit at all proved actually they
proved it before Grover's algorithm was
even known to exist ok is that that's
the best you can do ok so even with a
quantum computer you know ok yeah well
instead of 2 to the thousand steps you
can do it with 2 to the 500 steps you
know and that's awesome but 2 to the 500
still a big number
right you're not turning an exponential
into a polynomial you're you know you're
somewhat expanding the the size of the
problems that you could handle okay so
as far as you know we can see that you
know this may be like the best kind of
quantum speed-up that you can plausibly
hope for for solving np-complete
problems with a quantum computer okay
but we still don't know right what we do
know is that if there is a fast quantum
algorithm to solve np-complete problems
which you know again would be like the
holy grail of computer science you know
and you know you know 500 times more
important than you know then merely
factoring and those things
okay well then somehow it would have to
exploit the structure of the problems
just as a classical algorithm would have
to okay so then the question becomes
well is there are there any quantum
algorithms out there that would try to
exploit the structure of np-complete
problems so there is one very important
one which is called the adiabatic
algorithm okay proposed by Ed for hey my
other former colleagues at MIT like 17
years ago and I don't want to go into
the details of how this algorithm works
but if you've seen like local search
methods you know things that just sort
of store it at some random place and
makes a bunch of local improvements do
some hill climbing it's basically you
know it's basically like a quantum
version of local search a quantum analog
of simulated annealing in particular
okay so now these are not algorithms you
know that you know typically we can
prove will work but you know you can try
them out and see what happens okay and
so some of you might know that there is
a company which was founded you know
just around trying to build
special-purpose devices to run a sort of
noisy version of this quantum adiabatic
algorithm okay the company's called
d-wave you know they were on the cover
of Time magazine and they were you know
they've gotten a huge amount of
attention for it they actually have sold
a few of these devices
one to Google one to Lockheed Martin I
think I think a couple of others you
know their latest model has about 2,000
cubits
you know superconducting qubits right
and you may wonder well why have I been
talking about you know 20 cubits or 50
cubits
if d-wave already has 2,000 cubits right
and they're already selling it you know
to customers and you know well the issue
is there's actually two issues okay
first there's sort of the engineering
issue that you know that these qubits
just don't seem to maintain their
quantum coherence very well okay they
you know they're sort of like they're a
technology that is optimized for you
know getting as many qubits as you can
as fast as you can rather than for
making the qubits as good as you can
okay and you know many of us were sort
of doubtful that you know that with
qubits that are that noisy that you that
you would see a speed-up you know that
you that you could you know even if
there were one to be had and the second
issue is a more theoretical one you know
the issue is well you're trying you know
D waves entire approach is based on
trying to solve np-complete problems as
I mentioned these problems seem pretty
hard okay and you know it's not clear
that even if you could run this
adiabatic algorithm perfectly that you
really would see much speed up for these
problems okay may you know probably you
can see a Grover type of speed-up you
know a square-root speed-up maybe even
that you know is not certain because you
got to compare against classical
algorithms that themselves are very
clever and that could be much better
than brute force right but you know are
you gonna see an exponential speed-up
you know we don't know right you know so
there was a hope about it that you know
the this adiabatic algorithm could take
advantage of a phenomenon called quantum
tunneling which basically says like if I
have like if I'm trying to you know find
the minimum in some potential but I have
a spike sort of along the way that's
blocking me well then we're a classical
particle might get stuck over here for
exponential time you know a quantum
particle
can actually get over the spike you know
in a much more efficiently in polynomial
time right this is a very important you
know like this effect is central to why
you know the hydrogen atoms in the Sun
are able to fuse into helium for example
okay they have to get over a barrier
like that okay but uh so you know so you
know we could exploit that
algorithmically but then you know when
we're trying to solve real-world
optimization problems well is the
fitness landscape actually going to look
like that well you know who knows and if
it does look like that maybe you could
design a better classical algorithm you
know that would take advantage of it
right so so so people studied this for a
while and what what they found is that
the amount of time that you have to run
this adiabatic algorithm for if I want
to end with the solution to my
np-complete problem is determined by
something called the minimum eigen value
gap of my Hamiltonian don't worry what
those words mean okay basically I see
you know I have a graph with two things
and the you know and I look at the
closest that they ever get to each other
and however close they get I need to run
my algorithm for the inverse of that
amount of time okay and so then people
you know you know you know for he and my
other physicist friends looked at this
and they said well you know well you
know why are they gonna magically get
super duper close to each other right
you know and that's the only thing that
would cause the algorithm to fail okay
but then people studied it on you know
they looked at it on hard instances of
np-complete problems you know
satisfiability you know things like that
and lo and behold they found that this
gap does become does seem to become
exponentially small right you know it
was hard to to tell from the numerix you
know and there was a big debate about it
for a few years okay but far he has told
me the wonderful story that he wants you
know went to an expert in condensed
matter physics because you know for
their own reasons they have decades of
experience calculating these spectral
gaps okay and he asked well based on
your experience with sim
systems do you think that you know in
our adiabatic algorithm that this
spectral gap will will decrease
polynomial e or exponentially as a
function of the number of particles okay
and this expert thought about it a bit
and he said I think it will decrease
exponentially okay now that was not the
answer that far he wanted to hear so he
said why what's the physical reason for
it okay and the expert thought about it
some more and he said well it's because
otherwise your algorithm would work okay
so so so you know I mean you know after
you've seen enough examples of nature
sort of just failing to solve
np-complete problems in polynomial time
you know you might be tempted to you
know just want to take that as a
fundamental principle or you know
postulate alongside no superluminal
signaling and the second war and so
forth and you might wonder you know
supposing I accepted that postulate
what else could I then use it to explain
okay so that's you know that that's a
direction that that interests me a lot
okay so you know I'd say it remains
unclear whether you really get a
practical speed up this way over the
best classical algorithms we might not
know for sure until we can really build
quantum computers and test them out all
right so a lot of my work you know in
the last you know six years or so has
been about this very unfortunately named
goal of quantum supremacy which
reasonably just means getting a clear
quantum speed-up not necessarily for
something useful but just for something
hard okay
and so my student alex arkhipov and I
had an early proposal for how to do that
which was called boson sampling okay
what we suggested was like a very very
rudimentary type of quantum computer
where you just generate a bunch of
photons you send them through a network
of beam splitters and then you measure
where they end up okay now what is that
useful for oh I have no idea okay but we
were able to give evidence that you
sample from some probability
distribution we're sampling from that
distribution class
classically would be exponentially hard
okay and so people have actually started
implementing this so far they've done it
with about six photons you know if you
want to outperform a classical computer
you probably need at least like forty
photons or something okay so that's that
that's a challenge but in the meantime
I'm also mentioned this group at Google
which is planning very soon to have a
forty nine qubit chip you know now as
far as we can tell a forty nine qubit
chip is probably still not useful for
anything okay but you know if we just
put a bunch of up quantum operations on
that and we use it the sample from some
distribution over forty nine bit strings
then we have pretty good reason to think
that well that is a distribution that if
you want to sample it with a classical
computer you know you'll need something
like two to the forty nine steps you
know maybe maybe a little bit better but
you know that's about the best that we
know okay and so you know so it's it's
not so hard that a classical computer
can't do it you know that's important
because you want the classical computer
to be able to check the results and you
know we only know how to do that but you
know using this exponential time
operation okay but you know it's hard
enough that you could clearly see that
this chip would be solving something
faster than the fastest classical
computer that we have on earth okay so I
think that that will be if and when
that's achieved you know possibly within
the next couple of years that will be a
real milestone for this field okay now I
had stuff about the firewalls and the
black holes because I am out of time
what I suggest to do is to just go to my
conclusion you can see you know what
well look at these graphics that I made
okay you know I have a Schrodinger's cat
I've got a wormhole alright so what I
suggest that I do is that I just go to
my conclusion and then you know if
anyone wants to ask me a question about
firewalls or something then I can tell
you about it okay so my summary is that
quantum computers are the most powerful
kind of computer allow
by the currently known laws of physics
there is a realistic prospect of
building them you know you know what I
like to say is that if you can build a
quantum computer and it works you know
that's the conservative possibility
right I mean you know when people come
to my blog let's say and they're you
know they're you they say you know this
can never be done I say well you know
you know in some sense I hope you're
right right because that would be a
revolution in physics right but you know
my you know I think for me the number
one application of building a quantum
computer is actually just to prove those
people wrong okay all the all the other
applications are just icing to me okay
so you know but what we've seen is that
you know even a quantum computer
contrary to what the popular articles
say you know is not this magic Oracle
that solves everything okay even they
have limits and the limits are sort of
so strange and sort of cut across you
know things you know in such a
non-trivial way I like to think no
science fiction writer would have had
the imagination to invent this right
it's you know people usually go wrong by
trying to round it down to something
that a science fiction writer could have
thought of okay okay but you know the
limits of quantum computers have
explanatory power you know they can
explain why spectral gaps behave the way
they do and the part of the talk that I
haven't gotten to I could tell you why
they might even help to protect the
geometry of space-time all right so let
me stop there for now so thank you Scott
why do you say that
these limits might help protect the
geometries oh you really want to know
all right
all right anyone wants to leave I won't
be offended all right all right so now
all right there's yeah there's you've
seen this guy you know so so you know
you know I know sort of never when I was
here at Berkeley doing my thesis about
quantum computing I have never imagined
that it was you know
it was gonna have anything to do with
with black holes like you know I just
you know read about them and you know
popular science the same as anyone else
okay there was a remarkable connection
that's really been made within the last
five years or so between quantum
information and quantum gravity okay
including a famously this black hole
information puzzle so this was a central
problem in modern physics which was
raised by Hawking in the 70s and is
basically you know well the the rules of
quantum mechanics are you know except
for measurement which let's just forget
about measurement for now okay but if I
just have a bunch of qubits and they're
revolving on their own then everything
they do is time reversible okay so you
know I can run things backwards as well
as forwards and information is never
destroyed okay but a black hole seems to
violate that right I if I you know take
some bits or I take an encyclopedia or
something I throw it into a black hole
well and you know general relativity
tells me it's gone right it's sitting
the singularity is never getting out
okay so you know this seems the you know
the universe seems to have an
information dumpster okay you know which
then the question is how do we reconcile
that with quantum mechanics okay well
Hawking also famously oh yeah this is
might does my animation right so Hawking
also famously discovered in the 70s that
black holes radiate okay so you know is
there not completely black you know
actually photons slowly come out you
know for a black hole the mass of the
Sun it may take about 10 to the 67 years
for this to happen but you know
eventually the black hole will go away
okay but the trouble is you know his
calculation also said that the radiation
that comes out we know it suggested it
would be completely thermal completely
uncorrelated with whatever came in so
the puzzle remains okay and there's a
bunch of possibilities you know none of
them very appealing
right if it stays there forever we
violate quantum mechanics you know it
comes out okay well you know you know we
could imagine that somehow by some yet
unknown physics the information that's
dropped in what it would would would
would come out in some scrambled form in
the Hawking radiation okay but then that
leads to a problem as well because from
the perspective of someone who was
inside the black hole well the
information doesn't come out right it
just you know hits the singularity and
go splat okay so so now you seem to have
two copies of the information and well
why is that a problem well it's because
of I have a quantum state then there's a
basic principle of quantum mechanics
called the no-cloning theorem right
which says that there is no way to
actually make a copy of an unknown
quantum state okay this is you know this
is the central principle by the way that
enables quantum cryptography and other
possible applications such as quantum
money which would be physically
impossible to counterfeit okay that you
know but but I digress that's a
different talk okay so so then people in
the 90s started developing a view called
black hole complementarity which says
that actually you know you should not
even think of the interior of the black
hole as being a different quantum state
than what was you know available to you
outside of the black hole you know
including on its event horizon okay you
should just think of them as different
regan coatings of the same quantum state
and then jumping into a black hole
you know is just a really weird way of
measuring the same quantum information
that you could have measured had you
stayed outside the black hole all right
well you know that seemed the you know
sort of resolve the problems for a while
I was always confused about it and then
what happened in 2012 is that a bunch of
physicists decided that they were
confused about it - okay and so then you
know this led to a you know a big you
know a huge sort of discussion in
theoretical physics which you know you
know even spilled into the New York
Times and so on you may have seen
something about it it was called the
firewall paradox okay so what is this
was my um Harry Merrill polchinski and
solely in 2012 and this was sort of a
challenge to this black hole
complementarity and so it was a thought
experiment where you know the idea is we
would form a black hole we would have
complete knowledge of the you know the
entire quantum state of all the in the
in fowling matter you know it's a
thought experiment okay and you know we
let it form a black hole then we let the
black hole mostly but not completely
evaporate okay you know which takes you
know ten to the sixty seven years or so
we'll assume we have a really good grant
okay and and then you know as the
Hawking radiation comes out we route all
of it into our quantum computer okay we
just treat it as a collection of qubits
we process it in a certain way and then
we make some measurement which will tell
us that a you know that a hawking photon
is just now coming out of the black hole
is entangled with all the photons that
previously came out okay and and then we
jump into the black hole okay for the
sake of science and and we look at
what's happened and now there's a
principle of quantum mechanics called
monogamy of entanglement it says that if
I find a qubit and it was already
entangled with a second qubit then it
can't also be entangled with a third
qubit okay but now there's a more
principles in quantum field theory that
say as I fall into the black hole you
know yeah you know here's Alice it's
always Alice some reason okay you know
she she jumps into the black hole and
now you know it's and now because these
two qubits were entangled you know the
the the qubit that's just now coming out
of the black hole cannot also be
entangled with a qubit that's just
inside the black hole okay but Hawking
says if you want to see a smooth
space-time at the event horizon then you
need that entanglement that straddles
the event horizon right and you know it
sounds crazy but in quantum fee
theory space-time is built up out of
sort of a huge amount of local
entanglement if you don't have that
entanglement
you've got no smooth space-time which
basically just means space and time and
at the event horizon okay
and Alice encounters well you know an
end of space-time which was called the
firewall okay now why is that a problem
well Alice was supposed to encounter an
end of space-time but only at the
singularity right and this is saying she
would hit it hit one much earlier that
she can't even cross the event horizon
okay so then the question is what gives
right you know and and but you know what
made this a big deal is that it's not
just a philosophical problem right it's
like if you claim to have an answer then
you have to say well if Alice did this
then what would happen okay so so there
have been a whole bunch of you know
suggested you know resolution there have
been hundreds of papers about this
paradox okay but you know one of the you
know maybe the the most interesting
things that's been said about it was
said by Daniel Harlow and Patrick Hayden
and what they did is they said well yeah
it's true that you know black hole
complementarity says that you know the
you know it implies that that that Alice
could do some quantum computation on the
Hawking radiation that would show her
that there is this entanglement you know
and therefore you know create a
breakdown of quantum field theory at the
event horizon okay but let's now ask
well how hard of a computation which you
have to do okay and what they did is
they argued that the computation seems
like one that would be exponentially
hard even for a quantum computer okay so
you know take time exponential in the
number of Hawking photons that she's
dealing with okay so what do we mean
there we'd mean you know she can't do it
in a mere ten to the sixty seven years
she can't even make a dent in it in that
time she instead needs two to the ten to
the sixty seven years okay so by the
time that she had done this the black
hole would have already evaporated
anyway so maybe there's nothing to jump
into so maybe there's no problem
okay so that was you know that was kind
of what they said and you know now you
can you know have your own view on you
know how house weather weather that
satisfies you or not but you know when
they the thing that blew me away was
that when they came to the crucial point
why is this an exponentially hard
problem they drew on sort of all the
work that we had done over the last 20
years in understanding what are the
limits of quantum computers and in
particular you know their argument sort
of relied usually on this thing that I
did at my PhD thesis here at Berkeley
okay which is the thing you know the
sort of best-known thing that I showed
in my in my PhD was had to do with the
ability of quantum computers to find
collisions and something called
cryptographic hash functions okay so you
know a hash function is like a function
that map's you know some string to a
much shorter string and they're super
useful in cryptography but the key
property that they're supposed to have
is that it has to be intractable to find
two different inputs that map to the
same output okay and and so what I
showed is basically that you know if I
have just a black ash function that's a
complete black box just like that
setting that we talked about earlier
with Grover's algorithm that in that
case even a quantum computer will need
exponentially many queries to find a
collision in that hash function right it
turns out that like if let's say my hash
function has n possible outputs then
classically finding a collision takes
about square root of n steps right Y
square root of n well because of the
birthday paradox you've heard of that
right that's why by like if there's 23
people in a room there's even odds that
two of them share a birthday what
matters is the number of pairs of people
okay now it turns out that a quantum
computer could find a collision in such
a hash function using only cube root
event steps you know I'm not making this
up okay you know and you get cube root
of n by sort of
combining the birthday paradox with
Grover's algorithm in a clever way okay
so what our work showed in 2002 is that
actually even with a quantum computer
cube root of n is the best that you can
do okay now what Harlow and Haydn argued
was that you know actually you can sort
of take this collision problem is
finding collisions in a hash function
and you can embed it into the problem of
decoding the Hawking radiation that is
coming out of a black hole in such a way
as to create a firewall okay you know
you can sort of reduce one to the other
okay so that you know if you had a
generic efficient algorithm for decoding
as Hawking radiation then it would you
know it would let you find collisions
and hash functions which you know we
think is hard for even for a quantum
computer okay so now recently I
strengthened their result show that you
know performing this computation is
actually you know actually doesn't you
know is it's hard eve even even without
using my PhD thesis ok so you know in
fact if you could do it then you can
invert lets go you know basically any
one-way function using a quantum
computer ok which you know which would
let you break not just public key
cryptosystems like RSA and so forth but
even any private key cryptosystem you
know that's based on any mathematical
assumption ok so you know so whether it
solves the problem or not the problem
indeed seems to be hard you know so you
know and and and in what's happened in
the last 5 years is that cut you know
computational complexity has been
feeding back into fundamental physics in
all sorts of ways so I have a recent
result you know about well you know
you've heard of the schrödinger's cat
experiment right and and you know people
wonder if I had you know if I maintain a
cat in a superposition of alive and dead
states well you know like like well you
know what does it mean do I have to talk
about two universes that you know are
both somehow existing you know which is
the many-worlds philosophy ok and what
what my result says is that if I had the
technological ability to you know make a
Schrodinger cat I
then measure it and confirm that it was
in this superposed cat state then I
would necessarily also have the ability
to bring a dead cat back to life okay in
the sense that the quantum circuit
complexity of one task is basically the
same as you know the as the size of the
circuit that I would need for the other
task okay so you know so in the dead
state is not clear you know we should
even call the cat dead any al I mean
it's thinking I was alive it's dead it's
live it's right so I mean you know in
fact the schrödinger's cat experiment
involves way less animal cruelty than
isn't you know normally suppose okay
okay and then you know the craziest one
to me is that since you know about four
years ago
you know there's um you know been a
whole bunch of well people who call
themselves string theorists you know led
by Lenny Susskind at Stanford who now
like they don't talk about strings
anymore okay they are speaking in a
language of qubits and quantum circuits
and entanglement you know and and this
is now what they talk about okay and a
lot of the reason for that has to do
with what's called the ATSC ft
correspondence which is like one of the
most important things to have come out
of string theory and it's sort of a
holographic duality which relates
physical theories in different numbers
of dimensions and this is sort of one of
the best handles that anyone has on what
a quantum theory of gravity can look
like okay but the crazy thing that
people found was that when you like I
can take some situation like involving a
general relativity like for example a
wormhole between two different regions
of space and you know general relativity
says that a wormhole will just continue
expanding forever okay it'll just get
longer and longer and in fact the
standard wormhole and relativity is not
reversible right I go in and I can't get
out the other end cuz it's you know so
now you know like like what else do we
know that sort of somehow a connection
between two things and yet doesn't let
you send a signal from one to the other
well quantum entanglement okay and so
what's been what's become increasingly
clear
these two things are extremely related
to each other in particular when you
take these holographic dualities if I
take a wormhole and I look at what it
corresponds to unlike this boundary
theory this quantum field theory that
lives on the boundary then I find an
entangled quantum state okay and as the
wormhole gets longer and longer the only
thing that is changing about that
quantum state that would sort of track
the length of the wormhole
seems to be that this quantum state gets
more and more and more complicated okay
but you know what do you mean
complicated how can you quantify it
well Susskind proposal is that what we
mean is literally the quantum circuit
complexity of that state meaning like
the number of you know operations that I
would need to prepare that state using a
quantum computer okay so because of this
connection circuit complexity is now as
now started sort of playing the role of
like a fundamental quantity in physics
you know at least you know in the
context of ATS CFD so I don't know where
all of this is going but you know I sort
of have no choice but to you know you
know when they come to me as you know
you know well you know what do I know
about wormholes or black holes okay but
you know if they want me to use me as a
computer science consultants you know
and they can boil down their question to
something about quantum computing well
you know we're here to serve alright so
that so thank you for asking that was
the answer there
[Applause]